this is phospho gluco isomerase in 3d so
get your VR headset in place and let's
journey into this enzyme if you don't
have a VR headset head on over to the
video description and find the link for
the 2d experience I've made for you you
may see phosphoglucose isomerase called
a few names one of which is glucose six
phosphate isomerase but both of these
names contain the same information in
glycolysis the molecule that acts as the
substrate is glucose six phosphate or
g6p and it undergoes an isomerization
reaction forming fructose 6-phosphate
which we'll call f6p isomerization
changes the arrangement of the covalent
bonds in a molecule but the chemical
formula of the isomers is the same delta
g for the isomerization reaction of g 6
P 2 F 6 P is negative two point nine two
and at cellular pH it's calculated to be
a positive one point six seven what this
means is that the isomerization reaction
is pretty close to equilibrium Delta G
and Delta G naught prime are both
hovering right around zero therefore the
reaction performed by this enzyme is
reversible the relative concentrations
of g6p and f6p in the cytoplasm of the
cell will determine whether the enzyme
will catalyze the forward or reverse
reaction so this enzyme is important in
both the glycolysis pathway which breaks
down glucose to produce energy and the
gluconeogenesis pathway which makes
glucose from non carbohydrate sources in
this video I'll refer to phospho glucose
isomerase as PGI
the active form of the PGI enzyme is a
dimer which means two chains of the
protein come together to form the active
enzyme because two distinct polypeptide
means come together this enzyme has
quaternary structure which not every
protein has let's color one chain white
and one chain magenta so we can see each
clearly in this cartoon representation
or rendering of the enzyme this dimer
has a lot of symmetry I want you to
focus on these beta sheets right here on
the half of the dimer that we've colored
white now I'm going to turn the protein
180 degrees notice this similar section
of beta sheet on the other side which is
composed mostly of the magenta chain
let's change our representation to
space-filling where each atom of every
amino acid in the protein is represented
by a sphere to show its surface I love
this rendering because it gives a clear
view of how the dimer is intertwined
it's like one chain of the enzyme is
giving the other a hug now let's switch
to the surface rendering of the protein
keeping our coloring the same each half
of the enzyme contains a fully
functional active site in this structure
the enzyme is bound to an inhibitor
shown in green sticks the inhibitor is
bound to both active sites and if we
zoom in a little bit more we can see
although this active site is mostly made
up of the site of the dimer we colored
white some of the magenta half of the
dimer is part of the active site too in
fact some of the amino acid residues
from the magenta side participate in the
chemical reaction on the white side so
dimerization is critical to enzyme
activity you may be wondering how the
dimer is actually held together in the
body the interactions are the same weak
interactions that hold substrates and
inhibitors in active sites like we saw
in my hexokinase video here we have a
hydrophobic interaction this
phenylalanine is interacting with both
valine and leucine residues and these
distances of about 4 angstroms measured
from each atoms nuke
are fairly representative of hydrophobic
interactions involving atoms of this
size perhaps a better way to view the
interaction is to change to a
space-filling rendering notice how close
the surfaces of the amino acids are here
they actually appear to touch these
hydrophobic side chains cluster together
in interactions that exclude water from
that area of the enzyme moving over here
we have a hydrogen bond the implied
hydrogen atom on this o H group of the
threonine sidechain is hydrogen bonding
to the carbonyl oxygen of this glutamine
residue hydrogen bonding is stronger
than hydrophobic interactions notice the
distance between the nuclei is shorter
this one being 2.8 angstroms
finally let's look at a potential I on
ik interaction aspartate is negatively
charged at biological pH and lysine side
chains typically gain a proton in the
body becoming positively charged before
we examine the active site of PGI in
detail we need to look at the reaction
mechanism this isomerization reaction
actually looks a little extreme how on
earth are we going from a six membered
ring to a five membered ring well the
reaction doesn't actually occur on the
closed form of the sugar first the
enzyme opens the ring a proton is
removed from the O H group on the
animerica
carbon using a basic enzyme residue the
opening is facilitated by a protonated
amino acid within the active site that
donates a proton to this oxygen atom as
the ring opens since the reaction occurs
on the open chain let's compare those of
glucose and fructose
now instead of looking like a drastic
rearrangement of the carbon skeleton we
can see the carbonyl group has simply
moved one carbon atom over the
isomerization step begins when the
enzyme removes a hydrogen atom from the
carbon next to the carbonyl carbon of
the aldehyde this forms an enol a very
common intermediate and biochemical
reactions this intermediate is actually
called an IND I'll because there's an
alkene here and two alcohol groups in
dial to complete the reaction a basic
enzyme residue deprotonates this alcohol
and the electrons left behind form a
carbonyl this time a ketone and the
alkene gets protonated by the enzyme on
the other side the sugar ring can again
close before the product is released
from the active site there are several
crystal structures of Rabbitt PGI that
give us some insights into how the
active site residues catalyze the
chemical reaction the overall structure
of the human and rabbit form of this
enzyme is very similar and the active
site amino acids are totally conserved
in fact even the active site a bacterial
PGI contains identical amino acids to
the human form in this structure the
crystallographers captured PGI
bound to the cyclic form of fructose
6-phosphate in gluconeogenesis this is
the substrate of the reaction so to
begin the ring must first be opened
being a basic amino acid histidine can
become protonated this histidine here is
very close within hydrogen bonding range
of the Ring oxygen so this is likely the
proton donor the active site is a
special environment and depending on the
amino acids and substrates nearby many
basic and acidic amino acid residues can
switched from being protonated and
deprotonated to promote Catala
the crystallographers that solved this
crystal structure proposed that this
lysine instead of being formally
positively charged is hydrogen bonding
to the hydrogen atom on this water
molecule this allows the water to behave
more like hydroxide and be a better base
since its other hydrogen atom is tied up
with a lysine the lysine nitrogen
deprotonates this water becoming
formally positively charged while the
oxygen atom of the water deprotonates
the hydrogen atom on this o h group of
the sugar this allows the ring to open
up with the help of the histidine
residue we looked at just a moment ago
here is the open chain form of glucose
6-phosphate
notice the aldehyde and the phosphate
group here there's a compound quite
similar to this called six phospho
gluconic acid or 6pg they both contain
six carbon atoms a phosphate group and a
carbonyl group the big difference is
that 6pg contains a carboxylic acid
which is negatively charged at
biological pH instead of the aldehyde
that glucose has the carboxylic acid
group prevents the compound from forming
a ring and can give us more information
about how the PGI enzyme may interact
with a linear substrate fortunately 6pg
is an inhibitor of PGI and there's a
crystal structure available for us to
look at examining the active site with
6pg bound we can see this glutamate
residue which is the basic amino acid
that deprotonates the open chain hexose
sugar to form the in dial intermediate
once it does that the now protonated
glutamic acid side chain can move over
and donate the proton back to the other
side of the alkene you see although
crystal structures can give us great
static images of the active site
proteins are dynamic shifting and moving
to interact with other molecules though
we're focusing on catalysis here we need
to remember that all of the amino acid
residues in the active site are critical
in determining the substrates that the
enzyme will bind here are some of the
important hydrogen bonding interactions
that form with the inhibitor 6pg and
these certainly contribute to binding
the open chain sugar substrates as well
notice that many of the hydrogen bonds
involve water mediated contacts protein
crystals are not dry hard crystals they
must contain significant water to
maintain a biologically relevant shape
since you and I and the rabbit this
protein comes from are mostly made up of
water if you enjoy diving into this
enzyme with me please like this video
subscribe to my channel and we'll look
at more macromolecules together in the
new year